hi remember the bad four out of five and
we're surprising buzz feeders with a
staring contest I get it
[Music]
my turn like okay thank you for guiding
me hi guys there's four of you yes oh my
god I like when they take the blindfold
off in that bird box thank you all right
now there is sweet who's your favorite
hero from queer eyes season three I
didn't choose this question I'm very
excited about a better balance between
women two men and so I'm a big fan of
all the strong women that we get mean
showcases and three it's a lot he
actually is a favor oh you don't know
who we are that's fine I know exactly
who you are
you just watch your hair tutorial Oh
yes thank you good bye pointing who
typically gets the most emotional over
hero transformation Oh
who could it be actually him you get
really emotional I do get a little
emotional
he gets more emotional in the walls she
gets emotional yeah it's the culmination
of a week really the dog is the newest
member of my family this season which
member of the Fab five does brouilly
love the most
II know Bobby Bobby Bobby Bobby Bobby
Savita
what was the funniest onset memory you
have some filming season 3 when he
shaved his beard off my name looked in
when that happened like everyone really
did truly think I was gonna have a
meltdown and I really had to be called
that directly wasn't fun was I think
that it was onions it was pretty funny
Oh in retrospect okay oh my god I
what sets season 3 of queer eye apart
from the first two okay we have more
women than we did in system one and
season two and the shock on your face
tells me you have not seen season three
yet not yet but don't worry about it
we're not we're not judging it's only
been three days it's not like you had
all weekend I'm speaking for me
personally it was more raw for me like I
feel like I shared more of myself than I
did before I got into my groove in
season 3 my category I was like I know
what I'm doing we're going straight you
really want everyone feel everything
yeah losing an episode really wow oh wow
oh wow
pull myself together cuz I'm gonna win I
lost
in the words of my mom that was a
classic over-promised under-deliver
three two one go
wow he is that at the time concentrate
thank you we're out here too you guys
are all so pretty
so are you ask me if each of the guys
were food which food with babies I'd be
a favorite Jonathan would it be the
limited-edition Doritos taco bell
gordita situation and ike to make a
question that would be it that's my
favorite food I love Taco Bell so first
of all I was gonna talk about idea
Mexican pizza
Kurama would be a pink starburst Welch's
gummy or any skittles or a double decker
taco honey oh yeah yes I take it back
Jonathan would it be a turnover from
from McDonald's in Japan oh yeah
Thanh would be a baked by melissa
cupcake yeah that's bulan what flavor
come
yeah you do love a good choice I know
Chuck a lot just to make it a little the
trendy issue to go for like a little red
velvet so it's actually just chocolate
with red food not me an impossible
people would be no right no be guessing
Bobby would be impossible burgers dipped
in a vat of red right yeah yeah yeah
okay quick question for the three of you
though what would he be Oh for me he'd
be like a lobster dish that's really
accessible yeah I'd really like easy
[Music]
cheese board or country Oh pepper cheese
dip or chicken fajitas you know that my
lobster I do love Lobster oh my god you
guys are awful okay you be what through
Oh pizza da a pepperoni but the
pepperoni has to be crispy and I need
those little pools of fat and never see
a little food that she's has to be
bubbly
[Music]